oh did the about face ali ran him down
that's right where'd it go
she's not not messing around down there
and brings lebron james back with her
we'll get to the spot
and take it away allie when you're ready
to roll
lebron a near triple-double for you on
offense we're used to those kind of
numbers from you but tell me more about
taking on the challenge of the jamal
murray matchup late in this game and
wanting to defend him
hell of a player one of the hottest guys
that we have in the bubble today
out of the four teams remaining so you
know i just want to take the challenge
um he's a tough guard very shifty has a
dual threat being able to
shoot the three well actually triple
threat shoot the three mid range and be
able to get to the lane but
just using my um using my length using
my athleticism and also
um you know just being smart i've been
in this uh for a long time and the worst
thing you could do
is put a great scorer on the free-throw
line so just high hands meet him at the
rim and hopefully um
hopefully miss a couple you guys
dominated on the boards tonight
specifically the offensive
rebounds how did starting dwight help
create that energy early and what was
the sense of urgency
dwight was phenomenal for the minutes
that he played i got his extra shots
when he was missing early on
you know we needed that out of him his
vintage him you know he's been there
he's
been
a league leader and rebounds for uh for
a lot of times in his career so
that was big time we knew coming into
this game we didn't rebound
at all last game and uh they dominated
us so we just try to turn the tide
how emotional was the last 24 hours for
you after the briana taylor
ruling and how did you channel that for
this win tonight
um very very heavy the emotions was
very high and i mean we have a teammate
on our on our team that's from
louisville
and region so as heavy as it's been on
us it's even heavier on him because
that's his hometown and
[Music]
i just thought i don't know if the case
is uh
i don't want to get into the case of
things of that nature but i know we lost
a
beautiful woman in brianna that has no
say-so
um and what's going on right now
and we want justice no matter you know
how long it takes even though it's been
so many uh so many days
uh so many hours so many minutes uh for
her family for her community
um i mean i got a daughter of mine at
home and and
a wife and my mom mean so many you know
predominant black women in my life to uh
to think about if they weren't here the
next day or you know think if they were
gunned down it would be something i
would never be able to forgive myself
or forgive who did it so um i mean
we're here playing this game and it's
very challenging on us it's very
difficult
um but at the same time our hearts is
with that family
with that city and um it's just so
unjust what's going on
sorry to be so long-winded it's just
it's a tragedy
it's a tragedy and um we just hope that
there's better days
you know and and you hope for better
days and then
spread love and not hate because that's
what it all boils down to so
you guys are here to share your voice so
no need to apologize thank you so much
for your time and we'll see you game
five
yeah very very moving post game
interview there by lebron james
continues to be a symbol of a player who
can play
so well continue to be the leader on his
team and
one of the signature players in the nba
yet
speaks so eloquently and so impactful
about what's going on around the country
lakers win game four they're up 3-1 in
this best of seven
series so long from orlando